-I want to talk about
your new movie,
"Spiral: From the Book of Saw,"
the number-1 movie over
the weekend.
-Thank you.
-Not too shabby. Number-1 movie.
-Not too shabby.
-I'll take number 1.
-I'll take it.
-Yeah.
-Dude, Chris,
let me talk to you about this.
-Scary, man.
-Frightening scary.
-Frightening!
-I mean, but then --
-You know what the scariest
movie I ever saw?
-What?
-"Fatal Attraction."
-Yes.
But I would say that really is.
-That's the real scary.
Ain't nothing scarier
than your woman finding out.
-Yeah.
-Goblins or vampires --
who gives a [bleep]
A mad woman?
Now, that is scary.
That'll make it hard to sleep.
-I'm watching the movie,
and it's honestly
some of the most
craziest stuff I've ever seen.
I'm just like, "What?!"
And then I heard that
you thought of this idea.
-I did.
You know what's weird?
I was at Guy Oseary's wedding,
and --
-That's where you thought
of the movie?
-I was at Guy Oseary's wedding.
Guy Oseary got married
in Brazil by the Jesus.
-Of course he did.
-And Madonna is there
and Bono is there.
Like, everybody is there
and all this and that, right?
And the head of Lionsgate was,
like, was kind of --
maybe not this far away.
But -- And --
[ Laughter ]
-That would be unnatural.
-Yeah, that would be unnatural.
And, you know, so, I'm like,
"Oh, I know this guy --
the head of Lionsgate."
I was like,
"Oh, you guys have 'Saw.'
You ever thought about
having some humor in it?
Just a little bit, you know?"
-Yeah, just one --
-Just a --
-One joke?
-And he thought
it was a good idea.
And he called me in,
and we had this meeting
like three weeks later.
And next thing I know,
I'm shooting a movie, like,
that summer.
-That's crazy.
-We got Sam Jackson in there.
-I love Sam Jackson.
-Who doesn't love Sam Jackson?
-What's he like to act with?
-He is -- You know, people
always go, "How did you get Sam?
He did you a favor."
"No, we got Sam a check, okay?
-If you pay Samuel L. --
-If you pay Sam Jackson,
he will show up, okay?
But if Sam is your neighbor
and you try to borrow a rake,
it'll cost you $1,000.
-Yeah. But you can
get the rake if you want.
-You can get the rake,
but it's gonna cost you.
So --
-He plays your dad.
-Yeah, he played my dad,
and it was great.
He's kind of method,
so he insisted on sleeping
with my mother, which was --
-That's not true.
That is not true at all.
-It was a little uncomfortable.
It was a little uncomfortable.
But she didn't mind.
-Alright. But did you -- Should
we set this up in any way?
-Just set it up.
-I want to show everyone a clip,
but I don't want too show much.
-Don't show too much, Jimmy.
Don't give away
the whole movie, Jimmy.
-There's handcuffs involved.
-There's stuff involved.
-Yeah, you'll see
what's about to happen.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Chris Rock in
"Spiral: From the Book of Saw,"
number-1 movie.
Take a look.
-[ Groans ]
♪♪
-You okay?
Hey.
Help!
-That's scary.
-Unbelievably well-done, bud.
Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-And I appreciate -- Chris Rock.
"Spiral: From the Book of Saw"
is in theaters now!
-Thank you!